[Music]
i don't know about you
but this election season has me stressed
so why not do some stress baking and
make a ton of cookies today we aren't
just making
any cookies we'll be testing out three
cookie recipes
written by first ladies and then my
roommates will come and try them in a
blind taste test
and see who has the best cookie
let's do it first up chocolate chip
cookies combine the flour
salt and baking soda in a medium bowl
in a large bowl we're then going to add
our vegetable shortening brown sugar
granulated sugar and vanilla extract
we'll beat that on medium speed
until creamy add the eggs and mix those
until it's light and fluffy
gradually add our flour mixture and then
we'll mix in the oats
she has you fold in some chocolate chips
until evenly distributed
and using a rounded tablespoon drop the
batter onto greased baking sheets
and there you have it chocolate chip
cookies
i'm not even gonna tell you what's in
here i just want you to taste it and
experience it
it's not like dry it's not crunchy it's
almost chewy
i really like the texture a lot so
there's oatmeal in this chocolate chip
cookies
like why put oats in a perfectly good
chocolate chip
cookie you know but honestly i think
this is what this cookie needed
this is probably the best chocolate chip
cookie i've ever had yeah i love it
nice we'll be back next up we have sour
cream star cookies
she has you mix together the flour and
baking soda in a medium bowl
then we'll bring in a large bowl and add
butter and powdered sugar
we'll mix that until it's smooth and
creamy and then we'll add the egg
and egg white sour cream and beat that
until it's light yellow and fluffy
next we're going to gradually add our
flour mixture into the wet ingredients
beating until they're just combined
we'll then shape the dough into two
discs
and wrap them in plastic wrap
[Music]
liberally flour your surface and roll
out your dough until it's about an
eighth of an inch thick
and then using a two inch star cookie
cutter cut out as many cookies as you
can
and transfer them to a greased baking
sheet
and here you have it sour cream star
cookies
i don't really taste anything i feel
like if they put some icing on it
some red white and blue spruce it up a
little bit i don't like this one
it needs some sugar i like the shape
it's festive
last up we have citrus shortbread
cookies in a large bowl
add one and a half cups of butter and
caster sugar and mix that on medium
speed until
smooth then we'll add our egg yolks and
beat until fluffy
she has you add in two tablespoons of
amaretto
lemon zest and orange zest and we're
gonna mix those until just combined
working in batches we're gonna
incorporate our flour and salt
using the hand mixer on low speed until
no dry spots remain
just be careful not to overwork the
dough we'll then spread the dough evenly
into a 17 by 12 inch by one inch sheet
pan
making sure it's as smooth as possible i
had a hard time with this part so i
ended up using a bench scraper to really
get it smooth
we'll then brush the dough with egg
white and cover with the remaining two
tablespoons of sugar
and there you have it citrus
shortbread cookies all right so we have
our last
and final cookie guys digging
that's definitely different that's like
citrusy
it's super buttery lemonade cookies are
like
nuts or chocolate not really fruity but
this is good
definitely need some milk or something
with it definitely need some milk but
it's delicious
so we just tasted all three of our
cookies so now let's bring them all out
and
see which one these guys like the best
are you guys ready to pick the winner
[Music]
this one's really good this is easily my
favorite first of all looks the best to
me
tastes the best in the texture maybe
it's the oatmeal i don't know but this
is just
a really phenomenal cookie i'm tied
between the orange
shortbread and the oatmeal one i'd say
the orangey shortbread one is my
favorite
it has a really good chewy texture to it
and the orangey
taste really brings out the entire
cookie yeah this one's my favorite
so this one the sour cream star cookie
is melania trump's recipe
this oat chocolate chip cookie is
hillary clinton
and michelle obama made these citrusy
shortbread cookies
so you chose michelle's cookie and you
chose clinton's cookie
all right well you test them at home and
you let us know what you think
and remember go vote oh
yes